[Music]
the reality of gun violence that we face
in places like Chicago and unfortunately
not unique in many places around the
country is staggering on my above my
desk in Chicago I kept a picture that a
young young man 12 or 13 a middle school
student had drawn for me there's a
picture of him he's a fireman he was
climbing up a ladder outside a building
to assume to go rescue somebody and the
caption of his illustration was if I
grow up I want to be a fireman and that
for me was devastating because for me it
was never if I grow up it's when I grew
up and there are far too many young
people in Chicago and across the country
who ask or think if I grow up and
everything I've done all my life is to
try and have young kids think long term
and to defer gratification and think
about graduating from high school and
think about going to college
but if you're just trying to survive day
to day if you're just trying to make it
I'm speaking a foreign language I'm
speaking Greek and so the psychological
damage the fear the short-term thinking
that it forces you to have does so much
to take away kids dreams the biggest
problem for me is we've taken away kids
childhoods we have entire communities in
Chicago where kids can't go out and side
and play there are no playgrounds this
Friday where I can go build a playground
in one of those neighborhoods and do our
best to try and keep it safe so kids
could literally play and so all I want
to do is give children their childhoods
back and we've robbed them of that and
it's patently uh it's it's it's
absolutely immoral when I went on to run
the Chicago Public Schools for seven
half years obviously so many issues
you're working on improving academic
achievement and labor management you
know negotiations and budget issues and
capital I don't want to say any of those
were easy but they were all a heck of a
lot easier than dealing with the issue
of gun violence and the horrible truth
is during my seven half years on my
watch
on average we had a student killed every
two weeks and none of those thankgod
were in schools but they were in Jimmy
they were on the bus going home they
were this was star Keisha Reed who was
shot at 7:30 on a school morning 7:30
a.m. in her living room by an ak-47 from
a hundred yards away bullet through flew
through the window and hit her in the
head and she died instantly and going to
those funerals going to classrooms where
there was an empty desk and trying to
make sense of the senseless that was by
far the hardest thing that that I ever
dealt with this is a tough thing to say
but I always try and be honest what I
really thought
because vast majority might of my
students in Chicago were students of
color and or poor students what I really
thought is that the nation didn't care
about black and brown students and that
it would take white kids being killed
for anything to change and then in DC we
had the Sandy Hook massacre Newtown
Connecticut and that was obviously my
worst day in DC President Obama who by
definition dealt with the toughest
issues on the planet that was his worst
day he went down the next day to meet
with families Vice President Biden and I
went down a couple days later and none
of us ever imagined 20 babies you know
five teachers and a principal being
killed and then after that we got
nothing done in terms of gun control
legislation it's by far our biggest
failure and when you talk about lies in
education and lies in America what I
came to understand in that aftermath
wasn't just that we don't care about
black and brown kids that we don't care
about any kids we don't value their
lives we value our guns more than we do
their lives and so after that Sandy Hook
massacre seeing our inability to get
anything done in terms of gun
legislation for it first several years I
was honestly very very pessimistic and
that's not really Who I am I'm an
optimistic person by nature but I didn't
see much help and then tragically we had
that the massacre in parkland and what
those young people in Florida have done
to sort of awaken the nation's
consciousness has been extraordinary and
we've matched them with young people I'm
working with now in Chicago from the
south
from west sides who deal with this on a
daily basis they're working with young
people around the country they had that
March for our lives in DC that I took my
family my wife and our two kids too and
it was extraordinary to see and what I
actually believe now is that the young
people are going to win and they're
gonna lead the country where we as
adults have failed to take them they're
gonna lead the country to a place that's
freer of fear in Chama
is a nation we have raised a generation
of teenagers on mass shootings on gun
violence it doesn't happen in other
countries and when I meet with young
people I apologize all the time that we
have failed to keep them safe doesn't
happen in other countries but these
young people are leading a movement and
you study our history you think about
the civil rights movement you think
about the protests against the Vietnam
War
those weren't led by people my age or
it's my color hair those are led by
young people who are willing to put
their very lives on the line to try and
change America and so I'm actually more
hopeful more inspired than I've ever
been
there's a nation we're gonna break
through and our young people are going
to lead us where we need to go
[Music]
you